[Dawn] "I'm sorry brother." [Dusk] "You are
no brother to me nor to Cleon the first nor to
any other Cleon who walked these polished floors.
You are a deformity and if I had my way you would
already be ash." Hey guys, Pete here. Today
i'm going to explain the ending of Foundation
Season 1. The season just wrapped up with the
release of Episode 10 "The Leap" and it provided
some answers to lingering questions while setting
things up for the future of the series and season
2. Ii'm going to look at what happened to Hari
Seldon. What does it all mean for the foundation?
What happened to Azura and Brother Dawn and
the conspiracy there? What will happen to the
genetic dynasty and Demerzel? And what happened
to Gaal and Salvor Hardin? Just a quick spoiler
warning. If you haven't watched the entire first
season of Foundation on Apple TV+ including the
ending then this video won't be for you. And with
that out of the way let's get into it. Episode
9 ended with the death of Phara in the midst of
the conflict between the different factions of
the Outer Reach taking place on Terminus. Hari
Seldon emerged from the Vault and he seemed
alright with what was happening. in the finale we
get a better understanding of how he came to be
there and what it all means for Psychohistory
and the Foundation. He's a projection and he
explains to Poly who asked him if he was the ghost
that he took a pill that contained millions of
self-replicating molecular machines. those broke
his body down inside the coffin that he had made
and it recycled that material transforming into
the Vault on its way to Terminus. so the vault
is actually made of him but over those decades he
wasn't awake, he wasn't sentient that whole time,
he explains that his reawakening was triggered by
the Anacreon's arrival. he says that it takes time
to rebuild consciousness and when Salvor tries
to connect things to the null field expanding
he explains that it's just part of the vault's
natural defenses. Hari addresses the Anacreons and
Thespins saying that they've hated each other for
so long that the origin of their feud is almost
irrelevant and he explains that the first clone
Cleon II is responsible for setting things in
motion. the generations of hate between these two
cultures that we saw was ongoing in episode 1 when
they came to Trantor all traces back to what's
called the first betrayal where Cleon II had his
shadowmaster murder an Anacreon Grand Huntress and
blame it on the Thespin king she just married. the
point was that this marriage was going to bring
together these two emerging powers in the Outer
Reach and that would be a threat to the empire's
power. so the emperor decided to undermine that
knowing that it would get them to fight each
other and then he wouldn't have to deal with it.
now Hari says he needs them to put that behind
them and come together he selected the original
colonists on Terminus to have the seeds of a
future civilization and the others are survivors
they've been cast aside by the Empire and they're still there. under the genetic dynasty, there's only
room for one story and one voice and he believes
that that stagnation guarantees that the empire
will fall and that will be followed by a dark age that lasts 30 000 years.  it was always part of his plan
for these three cultures in the Outer
Reach to come together. he explains that he found
the pattern in the jumps of the Invictus and that
they're discovering it would be a potential step
ahead for the Foundation's development, he explains
that the idea of them curating knowledge for the
encyclopedia was only a cover story the Foundation
was never about that it was about curating people
and when one of the foundationers echoes what
he says about them not being revolutionaries
he says that he may have lied about that point.
there's still a problem in that the empire is
still going to come investigate what happened to
dorwan's ship who was there in the first place to
investigate what happened to the coms buoy harry
tells them that they won't come if they think
they're already dead and he tells them to use the
invictus to create a false mega flare something
like that would wipe out all life in the system
and therefore there would be no reason for them
to come into a situation where there might be a
dangerous star and a bunch of dead planets even if
it did host the foundation at one time after that
if they don't leave the outer reach they would be
invisible and more importantly they would be free
they can bide their time build up their strengths
and become what they need to be to shorten that
period of darkness according to psycho history
as he gets ready to return to the
vault they ask if they'll see him again
he expects that to be the case because
this isn't the foundation's first crisis
and it won't be the last they bought themselves
some time but war with empire is inevitable
he tells them to remember this day remember
what they're striving for and remember that
a thousand years can seem like a long time but
it's only a blip on the history of civilization
and if they're not vigilant this opportunity that
they have could slip right through their fingers
as he was talking he realized gail wasn't
there and that she never made it to terminus
in that exchange he meets salvor but it's clear
that he didn't anticipate her or know who she was
so as he's leaving she asks him about the visions
that she's been having and he doesn't know what
she's talking about she explains that she used
them to help her solve the crisis and he assures
her the divisions didn't come from him and then
the projection goes back inside the vault and it
closes up and it looks like it did beforehand
so what does it mean for the foundation we see
that the cultures are willing to work together
there's an exchange where rowan gives the grand
huntress his boat to salvor in an act of peace
and they plant a sapling from an acrion together
at the site of pharah's burial mari and the other
foundationers are angry they feel betrayed and
it's not so much that harry didn't tell them
what was going to happen but that he lied to
them salvor's in a similar situation she grew
up thinking that the ghost was talking to her
that harry selden was talking to her through the
vault she started to believe that she was special
and now she has no idea where the visions were
coming from there's a time lapse of the colony
growing over the next few months everyone has come
together and they're taking harry's words to heart
setting aside their hatred in favor of strength
and moving forward with the foundation they repair
the invictus and hugo becomes the captain he goes
out and generates the mega flare allowing them to
be free and now that they have the technology we
learn that it'll take them about 18 months until
they can start building new ships for her crucial
role in the crisis salvor is set to become the
next mayor but she has another vision where she
sees a young guy she goes to see her mother asking
her about who the girl from the water planet was
this leads to the big reveal that gail and rach
were her biological parents and the visions were
related to their memories rather than harry she
knows that gail escaped the slow ship in a cryopod
and decides that she needs to leave terminus and
go look for her she decides she wants to leave
right away because she's afraid that she'll
change her mind and her mother gives her her
blessing and the prime radiant to take with her
she goes to the beggar and hugo finds her before
she leaves they have their goodbye and we get an
understanding of where her head's at she thinks
this is something that she needs to do alone and
when he asks where she's going she just says that
she has a hunch and she leaves as has often been
the case in this first season where things get
really interesting is on trantor and what happened
to azorra brother dawn and the conspiracy brother
day has returned to the planet and his trip to the
maiden has changed his thinking brother dusk wants
to destroy dawn and replace him and when dae goes
to talk to him he says you're not one of us your
dna has been altered in a dozen ways he wants to
know how long he's known and this brings about
a really interesting conversation about how they
aren't even really people they're just echoes
of the first cleon and hasn't dey himself ever
wanted to leave this place be something more
than just an installment in this ongoing story
when he goes to speak with azor ah he explains
that he understands that people hate him but
says that his detachment from them is what
makes it possible for him to rule effectively
it's a strange burden not being able to carry a
burden the brothers care for each other they love
each other and they shift that burden between each
other he views don as his son he rocked him as a
baby he cultivated him and azora took all of that
away from him so he wants to take away her legacy
and they located every person family friends
lovers and so on anyone that would remember
her after she was gone it's a total of 1551 people
they have them all under surveillance and there's
a particle beam focused on their brain stem so
that when he gives the signal they'll all be
killed and right after he explains this he gives
the signal so they're all dead he then tells her
what her fate will be she'll be put into automated
extreme isolation where she'll be sensory shrouded
but she'll still be aware and he's doing that so
that she can remember what she took from him and
it's a brutal fate no matter how you look at it
demerizel comes to dawn she tells them it's time
and on their walk to the throne room he says that
she must hate him she assures him that's not the
case she actually loves him and when he says
that it's only because she's programmed to she
explains that all love is programmed biological
or otherwise saying that when a human mother looks
at her child their brain waves synchronize when
he's brought before dusk and day it's clear that
dusk hasn't changed his mind at all but he has to
default to the middle throne brother day explains
on his trip he had much time to reflect on their
dynasty he talks about the pilgrims he met who
worked their whole lives just to walk a spiral of
salt in hopes that they might be granted a vision
before they die he talks about the challenge
from halima he brings up harry selden how he
prophesies something similar and declares that a
bow and capable of bending will eventually break
he says it's time the dynasty bent just a little
brother dusk is not willing to go along with this
and they start fighting he's convinced that
it'll ruin their dynasty and he threatens to
decant another day rather than allowing the altar
dawn to live as they continue to fight dawn goes
to demisel for protection and she holds him like a
child stroking his hair brother dust shouts we are
empire history bends to us and as he's saying that
demmerzell snaps brother dawn's neck killing him
instantly when brother day protests yelling no she
tells him that she's loyal to the clionic dynasty
above all else after he disintegrates the body the
shadow master comes to him to say that the rebels
plans to undermine the dynasty appear to be more
extensive than they first believed they thought
the gene editing was limited entirely to brother
dawn's person and that it was done after he was
incarnated which is what the other clone told him
whenever he was in the scar after more testing
though they found out that the source itself was
adulterated as were the replacements those are no
longer pure copies so the source material is gone
brother dawn is dead and they can't replace him
with another pure clone even they himself
could be altered they don't know that yet
as well as brother dusk who's being tested right
at that moment he sends the shadowmaster away and
in a rage he smashes the glass case containing
the original clion the first then demmerzelle
goes back to her room takes off her salt bracelet
and looks in the mirror she looks troubled she
opens her kit and grabs a tool before tossing it
aside and then tears her face off as she screams
and with a lot of unanswered questions about the
future the trantor storyline ends there so what
happened with gail and salvor hardin well we get
one last scene that takes place 138 years later
we see gail arrive on cenex she's able to find her
home there's no signs of life there anymore maybe
not any on the planet at all as we see that the
water is much higher as she's mourning she sees
a light under the water and decides to go find
out what it is it turns out to be the beggar and
inside she finds salvor in a cryopod she gets
her out of the water and wakes her up and when
she asks her what happened she explains that she
crashed landed she's been in cryosleep for more
than a century and says that she was there looking
for someone which of course she was looking for
gail and she tells her i'm salvor hardin your
daughter and then she hands her the prime radiant
and the episode ends there so in the end where are
we at the foundation survived the first crisis and
came out of it with an alliance in the outer reach
that will make them stronger one version of harry
selden's consciousness exist inside the vault
to be a reassuring presence at the very least
the initial reason he got the encyclopedist exiled
determinus was a lie but things appear to be on
course for the plan in psycho history should serve
its purpose to shorten the dark age that will come
after the fall of the galactic empire periodic
crises are baked into that and harry should
re-emerge accordingly gail and salvo are mother
and daughter and they have these unique abilities
they don't quite understand they're together but
their future is uncertain considering they have
the prime radiant i have some ideas based on what
i know from reading the books but i won't go into
those here their being on cynix means that they're
somewhat isolated but considering the foundation
has at least one jump ship now they could be
reconnected without another prolonged period of
cryosleep either way enough time has passed that
things are completely different on terminus and
it's gonna take time for that story to catch up
to where they're at the clionic dynasty also has
an uncertain future the only thing that seems
certain is that it won't be carrying on like
it has for the last 400 years they left things
pretty wide open as far as whether brother dusk
and brother day were altered and there really
wasn't any progress as far as finding out who's
behind the conspiracy demarzelle's final scene was
fascinating and i think one of my next videos will
be talking about what i think's going on there
for now it appears that cleon the first altered
her programming to be loyal to the clionic dynasty
above all else and the things that she has to do
in relation to that or taking a toll on her it'll
be interesting to see how she responds to the
dilemma of having no new clones or pure genetic
material to continue the dynasty as they've
known it for a review this first season had its
issues especially in the structure and pacing of
the early middle episodes overall the terminus
storyline was noticeably weaker than the story
with the cleons and there were places where it
just didn't work for me i'm sure some of that can
be chalked up to the pandemic but it also felt to
me that they defaulted to try to do a cool action
thing in a lot of situations with mixed results i
do give them credit for the effort though looking
back they did a lot of crazy things and i think
generally speaking it's always good to see a show
that takes chances and i'm hoping that they'll
be able to identify what worked and what didn't
and come back with a much stronger effort in the
second season there was a lot of effort to develop
the characters and again i think this worked a
whole lot better on the trantor side of things
but as far as the finales concerned it felt like
a step up across the board in that department so
at least it feels like they're going in the right
direction there even with having so many different
stories that all felt somewhat different to tie up
in one hour-long episode from asimov they've got a
toolbox to pull from that includes some great
twists and turns based on psycho history and
the part they introduced themselves the genetic
dynasty has turned out to be a great addition
they managed to pull off some great sci-fi
and character stuff at the same time there's
so much rolled up in that dynamic and i'd loved
the progression of brother day through his trip
then coming back to his interactions with dusk and
dawn and azora respectively only to be completely
invested in what was going on in his decision
and then actually shocked at what demarzel did
the thought of brother day being on the verge of
changing things only to have it snatched away by
a fail-safe that we have to assume was instituted
by the original cleon that was the highlight of
the season the most powerful person in the galaxy
is trapped in that cycle there's really nothing
they can do to change things and now there's no
way to continue that so even with the issues it
had i'm pretty happy with where we're at i'm
curious to see where they go from here and i'm
glad i watched it and i'm happy that they made it
it was ambitious and sprawling and you can't take
that away from it this thing was huge in scope
and budget it was a proper spectacle at times and
there's a lot to like there if you go looking for
it and i think that's a good place to leave things
i do have a lot of questions though and i'll be
following this up with a season two questions
video sometime during this week so let me know
what questions you have for that in the comments
and let me know what you thought of the season
what you thought of the finale and if you want
to talk book spoilers just make sure you mark them
please like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you soon